producers are just deeply underrated
like so many of the songs that are
popular
right now or for the last 20 years like
part of the reason they're popular is
because the production is really
interesting or really sick or really
cool and it's like i don't think
listeners
um
like people just don't really understand
what music production is it's not it's
sort of like this weird
discombobulated art form it's not like a
formal because it's so new there isn't
like a formal training
path for it it's it's
um mostly driven by like autodidacs like
it's like almost everyone i know who's
good at production like i didn't go to
music school at school or anything they
just taught themselves are they mostly
different like the music producers you
know
is there some commonalities the time
together or are they all just different
kinds of weirdos because i just i just
hung out with rick rubin i don't know if
you've yeah la la i mean rick rubin is
like literally
one of the gods of music production like
he's one of the people who first
you know who like made music production
you know
made the production as important as the
actual lyrics or the notes but the thing
he does which is interesting i don't
know if you can speak to that but just
hanging out with him he seems to just
sit there in silence close his eyes and
listen it's like he almost does nothing
and that nothing somehow gives you
freedom to be the best version of
yourself so that's music production
somehow too which is like encouraging
you to do less to simplify to like
push towards minimalism
i mean i guess i mean
i
work differently from recruitment
because rick rubin produces for other
artists whereas like i mostly produce
for myself
so it's a very different situation um i
also think rick rubin he's he's in that
i would say advanced category producer
where like you've like
earned your you you can have an engineer
and stuff and people like do the stuff
for you yeah but um i usually just like
do stuff myself you're the engineer
the producer
and the
the artist
yeah i guess i would say i i'm in the
era like the post rick rubin era like i
come from the kind of like
um
skrillex school of thought which is like
uh where you're you are yeah the
engineer producer artist like right um
i mean lately
sometimes i'll work with a producer now
i'm
gently sort of
delicately starting to collaborate a bit
more but like uh
i think i'm kind of from the like the
whatever 2010s
explosion of things where um
you know everything became available on
the computer and you kind of got this
like lone wizard energy thing going
you